[Music]
in
weekend halloween news submitted by
hotel versus airbnb
thousands have signed a petition to move
the date of halloween
thousands that's nothing i know why
though two fridays every year
probably that would make sense friday's
every year no it's actually the last
saturday of october
they're trying to change it to the last
saturday of october
in order for the the holiday to be safer
and then that's cool yeah like the kids
don't have to worry like don't have to
cut their
halloween trick-or-treating short
because they have school that day or
adults because they have to work and you
know
if you party it hard then you can't have
sunday to recuperate it's usually like
on
some like tuesday or wednesday yeah it's
not like a holy holiday anyway but like
everyone in la celebrates like there's
half halloween parties here
it's exactly right it's like halloween
is like halloween week basically
yeah every weekend there's a halloween
party uh-huh you start with the weekend
before
they tell you more about like
trick-or-treating for the kids yeah
some for the kids and then also because
they're saying you know kids
statistically get
run over the most during that time they
shouldn't be so short though
they're hard to see at night yeah you're
saying 63 percent of children don't
carry a flashlight
while they're trick-or-treating
dumbasses
firemen always have reflective care
that's true that's true
firemen every year or maybe a bumblebee
with a really big wing that's smart
that lights up like it's edc or like
tron yeah if you can make
your kid light up like have them all
tron's but if your kid wants to be a
ninja he's [ __ ] yeah you can't be in
there he's gonna get smacked by that car
damn it isaac was a ninja one year right
wes did you lose him you were with him
like a responsible parent exactly that's
what i was reading about this i'm like
what the [ __ ] i forgot the number
because they don't they brought down the
change.org site so it's not up anymore
but there was this one statistic
that's i forgot the number but it said
that children ages five and under go
trick-or-treating without supervision oh
who the [ __ ] is hiding there do they go
with their
other friends though i don't care but do
they go with their
like like someone else's brother or like
in a big group
unsupervised especially if they're just
like batman that's dangerous
because like that's a dark costume
stranger things but they're not five
years old
five is [ __ ] young five is pretty
young alone and you're under
yeah that's pretty young crazy to me i
think eight is okay i think i went trick
treating by myself when i was eight well
not about myself but me and my friends
yeah me and my friends rollerblades and
stuff with the pillowcase one time i
went trick-or-treating with my little
cousin and i was hungover and i had
black makeup all over my face and it was
just because i was
hungover but i said it was a zombie that
was pretty good that's because he worked
it out yeah i did i did i
improvised the costume and i didn't lose
him like the whole time i just a couple
and see back then you couldn't have just
said i'm a real housewife exactly
that makes sense and when you open the
window did you scream what guys are
vampires
she's trick-or-treating yeah i was doing
it with him zombies don't scream they
don't thought like what which at which
weird animal is the one or the animal
but creature
the sun comes in like oh vampire vampire
i'm a yeah i'm a vampire for sure
every day yeah i feel like i'm a
cheerleader vampire i like halloween
so this this change.org got
over a hundred thousand signatures um
what can we do can we show them the
picture of that girl you're not supposed
to be lovely
sorry like i like that outfit i would
roll
literally in that and now i gotta see it
listen you're not gonna see it oh please
cause it doesn't even pertain to this
say describe it to me it's a [ __ ]
wheelchair
in old people too it's like you were so
incorrect
oh what's up but it's okay we're not
gonna talk about it oh
anyway it's paper mache what the [ __ ]
what is it i like how halloween before
we could be
as like racist and sexy and everything
that we're not supposed to be
but then i feel like now we can't do
that no more only sexy is okay i think
sex
is okay there's still there's no
discrimination against sex like is
ninja's cultural appropriation
like that yeah yeah yeah i just love
like i can like dress like a horn i'm
like it's an excuse
you know it's still okay yeah only on
halloween though right sid yeah
well i mean every day is kind of like
halloween for me but like i love sending
the naked
like west hollywood pictures to my dad
on accident
you know with like the guys that they're
like i have this amazing one that i do
like almost
every year he's got these feathers and
his dick is hanging out he's in full
fish
that's [ __ ] funny and you send it to
your dad i'm like oh yeah sorry
yeah oh you meant your own i was like
what is it that's what i thought
in here yeah no that's what i heard but
then i let her finish but i was like
they're cool i guess they're cool with
each other
[Laughter]
yeah i was hoping there was more to that
story i'm glad you finished it that way
why do they have like a halloween
halloween parade and they they're just
like their dicks hanging out and stuff
oh and west hollywood
no not a west hollywood halloween parade
i never did that it's [ __ ]
fun there's just a lot of i mean it's
not fun to see a lot of dick though
for me uh people get really creative
with their costumes they do yeah and
coverage of it and it does look really
fun it's very
like they get they go all out you ever
seen guar the heavy metal band
where they walk around gigantic like
[ __ ] costumes
when they have like huge dicks that like
like move around like animatronic dicks
they spray like fake comb all over their
audiences they should like that even
hollywood like the hollywood uh
halloween parade is the same thing
yeah they close it all off it's a whole
lot i don't know you can show dick in
public like that
you can you can that's crazy yeah my
dad's like born again boring a christian
so he really
he failed christianity and he still
falls for it
every halloween it's really funny that's
his fault it's so funny does he do you
think when you send it to him i hope
oh jesus christ i just wish i had that
reaction
video i wish i did that would be amazing
i would love it
mm-hmm i'm sorry you don't do that with
your family it's kind of a nice bonding
also my dad's a dick pic tonight you
should do it i'll send you one
two days now yeah my mom's the one that
sends it to me if she sees stuff like
that
oh is that right if she sees something
funny really yeah
it's like if she saw anything and like
she's traveling or whatever she would
email me send me stuff is it like a cat
hanging from like the side of a building
she's like oh it's so cute
i think my step-dad's even funnier that
but will take pictures of like
like pictures or advertisements at a bus
stop or something and he's like this is
a traditional dress
or like it's something [ __ ] obscure
as [ __ ] yeah my grandma does that too
about avocados she just sent me like the
health benefits of avocados i'm like
thanks graham
oh she can text though like that's
pretty bad
like 82. that's pretty good yeah i was
like you go girl
my dad sends me like um he's like hey
just so you know they just recalled this
kind of meat in this area and i'm like
okay cool oh it's not even in your own
area
well it's like no it's he thinks he
hears l.a so he's like oh maybe it's
where he's at but it has generally
nothing to do with me or anything
that's so sweet that is sweet so
going back to this halloween thing so
the people that
were trying to pursue changing the date
of halloween now they came
to a different conclusion so they're
saying like all right well
so by the way it's the halloween and
costume association they're the ones
that
i don't know there wasn't even a
committee halloween and costumes
halloween and costume
yes girl they proposed a new holiday
instead of changing the dates of
halloween
two uh so now it's called national
trick-or-treat day and that will fall
on the last saturday of every october so
there is a halloween and then a national
trick-or-treat day
so thanksgiving this thing because
thanksgiving is where it's like the last
thursday of every month exactly yeah so
you're supposed to go trick-or-treating
on the national day now and not on
halloween so i guess
so now they're calling it hashtag all
owene campaign
and that's to promote this new holiday
and they're just trying to say that this
is a safer longer stress-free version of
halloween so
it's like adding to the holiday yeah and
so they're hoping that
the majority of trick-or-treating will
be done on that day so it could be safer
for kids
that's cool i hope kids don't come to my
house two times in a week though true
because that's a good way to milk more
candy out of than
yeah i'm only going to answer one of
those days dude i'm going to run for
office one day i'm going to say why
don't we make halloween every [ __ ]
day
somebody's going to win dude you're
going to win so that's my whole platform
yeah
that's it someone's going to take that
[ __ ] dude like what about healthcare
and my eyes are closed over
like what about i think i think what
really everyone's asking is where the
candy is
yeah that's the main thing all of our
tax dollars are gonna go to candy yeah
yeah what's crowdsource candy we all buy
our own can you pass it out yeah but
like what's the dumbest like or worst
candy have you guys ever not had candy
and trick-or-treaters like show up
the [ __ ] mexican candy sucks yeah the
mexican candy
not the not the good mexican candy but
the [ __ ] mexican pack of candy oh the
cheepy ones
yeah they all have like peanuts and it
has like that strawberry you know what
i'm talking about like the strawberry
wrapper one that's like this obscure
[ __ ]
and then the chocolate i mean not
chocolate the freaking bubble gum
that yeah it's like hard as [ __ ] i used
to love dots but now they just get so
stuck in your teeth it's not it's just a
pain in the [ __ ] ass
we didn't even have name brand candies
okay what's dots it comes on a sheet
yeah no dots is those
the little they come in like a little
yellow box and they're very chewy no
those are dots
they're like little gummy they look like
bells oh like lemon drops
no no yes it's an asian thing you
wouldn't understand i passed out quest
bars one year because i didn't have any
[ __ ] candy
it was so [ __ ] that's expensive yeah
kids coming to your door though what was
my ex-boyfriend's house he was like a
fitness guy
and so like he didn't have any candy and
all the moms kept coming back for the
quest bars because they were so healthy
it was really funny he was a fitness guy
with edie no he wouldn't
have ed okay he was the rare exception
no just roid rage
totally different oh he was on stairs
i always want to try to pass out candy
but then the kids never come to my place
why because i live in a really hard to
get to place
that sucks because it's kind of fun to
see them all excited it's [ __ ] cute
oh it's so cute they knock
and then they're like trick-or-treat
they're like what are you do you get to
try out dad joke bits on them too
but the old ones are freaky you're like
dude you can [ __ ] rob me like get
away
right don't you get a little like scared
i can't relate
i haven't given up oh sorry one year i
didn't have a costume because
it was super last minute and i had like
no money and so i
i took my friend's tripod and i put it
over my head and i just went
door-to-door with it
like with a [ __ ] tripod on my head
and they're like what are you and i was
like i'm a european fashion model
i can see it yeah it's tight it looks
like some [ __ ] like that i'm like
there's no difference between this and
like a versace ad oh my gosh i love it
it's like zoolander my neighborhood
actually might do halloween finally
because i just moved into like a real
suburb kind of thing nice i better turn
off all the lights and not be home
wow oh you're that guy let me come over
and give candy
use your house i have to go somewhere
with my dogs because i don't want them
to be barking all day and going crazy
yeah
i want to do a haunted house where they
come in to it
and then it's just like like i i have a
like a sixer a beer and [ __ ]
and i'm like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
she's like you're such an [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] yeah and then i i throw like sugar
glass bottles at nikki and then she's
always like you get the [ __ ] away from
me i'm calling the cops
and then there's a crying baby in
another room now that's a nightmare
you want some candy but then there's a
there's a it's like take
one please take one in the middle of it
you have to kiss you have to go through
the fight
yeah like you have to walk i remember
that house in your old neighborhood that
he had like a
speaker system outside like someone
getting murdered and [ __ ] yeah it's
tight
yeah we're like wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you